hey guys how's it going it's Justine and
today we are unboxing the brand new
Microsoft Surface go it's basically like
a very tiny MIDI surface I'm a huge fan
of all the service products you guys
might know that half of my office is Mac
and the other half is PC and on the PC
side I've got a completely decked out
with surface products and this is gonna
be such a fun little thing to add to my
collection and just for the record this
video is not sponsored but they did send
this to me to check out so thank you so
much Microsoft let's get to the unboxing
these come in three different for
different colors we're gonna be platinum
cobalt blue and black I'm not sure what
color this one is I'm thinking that it's
gonna be the Platinum judging by the
outer rim the type cover
let's open little naive it's let's go
it's nice go small just cutting this
outer plastic is so satisfying oh that
shot you got that shot that real nice
close-up that real nice yes wow okay
this has gotta be the platinum because
the whole inside of the box is also
platinum oh it definitely is yes so
excited like there's a lot of things
that make me excited like candy and
cookies a new tech little instructions
I'm not interested in those right now
little charger everything is small like
oh it's not that small but compared to
the actual service it's a much smaller
look at this what's a tiny baby can I
freaking help you I have an upcoming
event well I can't go to it cuz I'm
unboxing
I'm not in my house I don't know where
all the outlets are I'm in unfamiliar
territory oh it's so small I mean it's
not actually that small it's probably a
very normal tablet size definitely a try
play for tonight on this it's probably
not gonna be the most optimal
performance that's your little stand
should probably try it on well that
starts up I'm gonna put up this mouse
the side of it is magnetic and we no
good trying to take my things these are
my things
actually it's Jenna's to be honest you
know you can have it back yeah I was
gonna say I think I bought this and we
went to Yosemite mobile mouse oh you're
like half the size of the normal Mouse
I'm Cortana and I'm here to help a
little sign in here a touch a Wi-Fi
there and we'll have your PC ready for
all you plan to do I've got big plans
this is your voice or the keyboard along
the way and if you'd like me to stay
quiet
just select the little microphone icon
towards the bottom of your screen I
would like if you talked to me cuz I
have been talk to you you need an
assistive screen reader the windows
control enter keys
okay enough in trouble let's dig in
let's dig I like what you said little
power but little religion is set to the
United States is that right
yes I even bought the inside of the
memory board is set to us want to stick
with that yeah
do you also type with another keyboard
layout no now let's get you connected to
a network
oh you can get apps then cat videos as
soon as possible yeah videos what's your
password about the first one you're next
brush my hair while I wait you're all
lit up come on okay next cool thank you
oh you want to see that shot at this
shot look at this keyboard too
[Music]
like what do you think they're doing
back there secrets Oh Oh several minutes
I'm gonna turn it off this thing is so
freakin cute
I love small things do you think you're
gonna do like an Excel spreadsheet a lot
of strategy PowerPoint I'll probably do
a spreadsheet
I like spreadsheets as well this isn't
we need to do we're gonna done one for
tonight and I'm gonna play it so I
didn't do this on purpose
I swear because I've had these nails for
several weeks but they match this like
it's so close all right well I'm
downloading fortnight and then let's go
take this outside and get a nice slo-mo
montage of me doing really cool things
like sitting and playing you ready for
that done okay
[Music]
[Applause]
I'm working on an extremely important
document so I'm gonna have to ask for
some privacy please please do not look
at my document chicken tender
I'm listening all my favorite snacks
this is a secret document stop looking
at my secret document don't look at my
dog look at it look at my document how
that's what you're typing I'm working on
a secret Excel document Tic Tacs I like
tic tacs
[Music]
[Applause]
we're playing for tonight on the surface
go and I'm actually really surprised how
well this is running let's go let's go
get some loot I just bought this new
pickaxe the stop sign
who wants to get eliminated hey ed you
wanna see this yeah can you take a look
at this like it's raining
yeah sure I like this room
me too yeah I know you're home go to the
basement that's a great
where we going bud oh my I'm still
shocked with how all this is running
which I am incredibly surprised
especially after playing on the MacBook
okay where you at
this table is huge and yours I mean
measure the table and know how how big
is this table let's see it it's like -
it
okay so - so we got one and okay I'm
gonna get two ads almost this is the
worst thing I've ever done No somebody
help me somebody help help help help
somebody help
what about painful ones that would be so
cool I'm getting revived by this homie
little goodies up there hey hog do you
want to die oh shoot no that was me I'm
dead my body does mud but just killed me
well guys that was for tonight on the
service go I'm shocked at how well this
brand because I did do a bunch of tests
when I was playing on the MacBook Pro
and it still ran fairly well in math
world but this ran way better than I
expected this does have 128 gig solid
state drive and eight gigs of ram and it
is so small and so tiny that you can
take it wait for it on the go okay let's
go get dinner and then I'll get myself
some b-roll of me going to dinner going
to dinner we might be going alone oh
cool we've gotta save my document
holidays closer no I don't wanna make
sure you don't want to lose this
important data
[Applause]
[Music]